I don't know how to describe being
awkward but I just didn't answer that
well hi I'm Lea hi I'm Emily I'm a
socially awkward person so today I'm
gathering a lot of other uncomfortable
people and we're gonna make them stare
at each other for four minutes
uninterrupted eye contact I've been told
that I am socially awkward by friends my
mom is really sweet though she's like
you're not that bad
I get very fidgety and shaky around new
people when somebody is looking at you
you feel very seen and I like to be very
unseen I am NOT excited to stare into
eyes today I would rather not do that
but we're here it's definitely really
vulnerable and I also don't know this
person at all I think four minutes of
uninterrupted eye contact will change me
as a person I'm not sure how but I'm
excited to give it a go oh my god I
don't wanna do this we're gonna do it
we're almost there Jesus all right ready
I feel nothing said we can blink Hey
yeah would be an impossible task oh my
gosh Oh God
[Music]
[Music]
so what didn't you do this weekend
I'm definitely blinking a lot
really yes oh all right yeah I'm like
blinking a lot
it looks like it seems totally normal I
suddenly became aware of every part of
my body he could not know that was
actually really good yeah that was fun
there was like a moment in time where I
felt like a warmness even though like
we're not friends I feel like I had I
sex with you like I think I'm gonna need
some time to recover but hopefully this
will be like a new baseline to be like
the four minutes was weird this
conversation is not I mean now that I've
done this I feel like I'll probably hold
eye contact a little longer than like a
second with somebody so like I kind of
feel like I tore down a wall a little
bit which is like weird
I think we've shared an intimate
experience today you know we can't we
can't go back we're bonded forever
[Music]
okay
[Music]